thank you
all right
problems
again
thank you
tonight
yeah of course yeah thank you for
contributing
folks if you want to just I'm gonna go
through the last few slides if you
already read them feel free to go if you
want to hear me read them you can stay
for like five more minutes up to you I'm
not offended
so
um you already know how to open a PR
um how many of you already opened a PR I
already started labeling congratulations
um
if you haven't opened a PR have you
already picked an issue or are you
working on an issue yeah great
um anyone thinks they'll keep working on
it after the workshop and find issues by
themselves
yeah awesome
um
so if you'd like to stay active in the
pandas contributor Community we have a
page that has when we meet when we
discuss we have meetings that are just
for newcomers every month we have a
slack and I have a QR code for you if
you want to join the slack so generally
we recommend that you ask anything that
you need help with on the issue on the
pr they need help with but if it's
something with your local Dev
environment or something you're just
like I'm not sure if it's only me or I
don't feel comfortable asking this
publicly on GitHub then that's what the
slack is for and at least that way all
of the other new contributors and so on
we'll see you know what the issue and
how we resolved it so
um it's just a smaller subset of the
community instead of everybody
um yeah we have monthly meetings for new
contributors
um that you could uh if you're working
on a PR and something isn't working
right I just want to explain it you just
want to meet with us you want someone to
help you figure something out you can
share a screen and work with some of the
maintainers
um sometimes we do demos Patrick is
going to do a demo about testing next
month
um and uh if you want us to organize
local events for you like this then you
can reach out to us we I regularly do
them here in Berlin but you can chat to
us about other opportunities
and
if you'd like to get more practice not
on public pandas where everybody sees of
the whole Open Source process of
contribution where you need to make a
fork and open a PR and how all of that
works this is a great project that just
teaches you how to do that or if you one
of your friends want to do it and you
don't feel comfortable necessarily
explaining with yourself that's a great
way what I like about it also that they
have it in very many languages and I
know English is not my native tongue
it's not necessarily everybody else's
native tongue so you can also review it
and see if it helps you
and if you need even more resources
about contributing to open source
um then I linked a few more things uh
then other projects that have calendars
when they have meetings all the a lot of
other projects in pi data ecosystems
have meetings for new contributors maybe
you'd like to try to contribute to
psychic learn or to numpy or something
else then you might want to give it a go
but also a lot of other videos data
umbrella one of our maintenance Marco
also did a how to contribute to pandas
video there so if there's anything you
want to review or have a look at these
are some amazing resources to keep you
going
so any questions you want to ask
no
well thank you all for contributing to
pandas
um and hopefully we'll see you on slack
and in one of the meetings
and you can you can stay until the end
it's just that I saw a bunch of people
leaving so I thought we'd do rep
ly yes
and then I'm uh
foreign
[Music]
confident
as well
everyday
the
indexer yeah
is that typically I think that was in
the series
you know
yeah
okay
thank you I mean it's fine